- [Narrator:] Chef Russell Wilson took over the Bronco last year...
And it quickly fell on hard times.
But now they're calling in the one guy
who may be able to save it.
- This is the worst run restaurant
in the history of restaurants.
- Are you always this mean
or is it just for the cameras?
- What's the most important part
of running a successful restaurant?
- That everyone likes me.
- What? No?
- I work front of house, so I have to defend whatever Russ serves up.
Lots of scrambles, the occasional duck, and a bunch of turnovers lately.
- You know,
my job is to run the plates to the tables,
but a lot of times
Russ just fakes the hand off.
- I'll just do it myself.
What’ll you have?
Our menu is unlimited.
- Menus need limits.
This is no way to run a business.
Between you and me,
the competition on the AFC Westside
isn't as intense as you think.
[Payton:] The Chargers
basically run a social media restaurant,
but it turns out ultimately,
they don't even deliver.
- Hope you left room for dessert, my dudes!
- Oh, god! It burns! Ahh!
- My leg!
- Why does this keep happening?
- [Payton:] The Raiders just hope
everyone gets distracted by the show.
- Excuse me. This is... not good.
- Yeah, that is correct.
- [Payton:] And with all the rumors, no one
can even get into the Chiefs restaurant.
- [Paparazzi:] Travis? Travis,
are you meeting Taylor Swift inside?
- Ugh, why is everyone making a big deal about this
thing I bring up all the time!
I mean, yes we won it for you, but it was also just the Bears.
- We made some big changes.
Russ finally listened to me
and agreed to wear a recipe wristband.
- But, it's so heavy.
- SERVICE TIME, CHEFS!
ALL HANDS ON DECK!